welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Dober
on this episode I talked with ajaya
Carter who's a senior research analyst
at open philanthropy
when will the World be transformed by
Advanced AI
the jail has produced what is perhaps
the most in-depth investigation of this
question
we talk about how to define
transformative AI
we talk about different methods of
forecasting transformative AI
what we can learn from the predictions
of AI experts whether AI development
will be limited by the need to interact
with the physical world regulation or
lack of training data and whether there
are human abilities that AIS cannot
learn
here's a jayakatra
at Jay and welcome to the podcast thank
you for being here
thank you for having me it's great to be
here
great you have this report that you
published in 2020 where you attempt to
forecast transformative AI with
something called biological anchors we
should walk through that title and
explain what is forecasting what is
transformative Ai and what is uh what
are these biological anchors
right so um transformative AI is this
term that Holden karnovsky from open
philanthropy coined in 2016
um that is meant to
talk about AI systems
um either one system or a collection of
systems that has an unprecedentedly
large impact on the world while trying
to be relatively agnostic about the form
that takes
um so the definition he gave then was AI
systems that have as much of an impact
on the world as the Industrial
Revolution
and in my report I operationalize that a
little more as AI systems that are
capable of causing a 10x acceleration in
economic growth
um because that was roughly as much
acceleration as happened during the
Industrial Revolution so growth was
roughly 0.1 percent per year before the
Industrial Revolution and roughly one
percent per year after right now growth
is two to three percent per year so
transformative AI would be systems that
could cause the economy to grow 20 to 30
percent per year forecasting that is
just when do we think that kind of event
would occur when would AI systems be
developed that would have that
capability and it may be the case that
systems are developed that have that
ability but they're actually put to
different uses so
um in my mind I'm thinking of it as
when will we develop AI systems such
that if we were just kind of selling
them in a free market using them
wherever they were profitable that would
cause a 10x acceleration and growth
there may be reasons why the people who
develop these systems decide not to use
it that way in which case we may not
observe the full potential of that
growth and it might instead be directed
toward EG having a military Advantage
um or other things
we should mention that this 10x increase
in economic growth it's not it's a very
rare event in world history yeah it has
happened once or maybe twice with the
Agricultural Revolution
uh yeah
um I think this is actually a little bit
complicated because
um there's a debate on how to view the
world historical growth there's kind of
two perspectives
um in one perspective there have been
one to two bursts of uh increased growth
where we go from one mode to another
like going from hunting and Gathering to
farming and then going from farming to
Industry
in another perspective there's actually
been
roughly smoothly accelerating growth
rates so a growth rate of one percent
per year means that the amount of stuff
we have is accelerating so you have an
exponential curve
um but you can also have that growth
rate itself be accelerating in which
case you have a super exponential curve
um that actually
if you extrapolate it all the way out
will
apparently reach infinity in finite time
but of course we would treat that as a
model and then we would eventually model
some limits to growth there
so there are kind of two perspectives on
one perspective with transformative AI
it's like
we've changed growth modes a couple
times before that could happen again and
transformative AI could be the thing
that causes us to change into a new
growth mode into a purely digital
economy or an AI based economy as
opposed to an industrial economy or a
farming economy or hunting economy
um from another perspective though
um transformative AI would be one more
thing that continues a trend of growth
rates accelerating through history
um and from that perspective what we
call the Industrial Revolution is like a
period we picked out where that process
was kind of above Trend and unusually
fast
um but not
massively special because before the
Industrial Revolution and after the
Industrial Revolution there was still
acceleration of growth just maybe like
slightly less sharp than it was in that
period
okay but under either of these models it
we're talking about an enormous change
to to the everyday life of people on
earth
how on Earth do we go about uh
forecasting this event what what are
these biological anchors you're talking
about in the report
yeah so um before I talk about the
biological anchors I kind of want to
back up and talk about simpler methods
of potentially forecasting this event
um so one thing I mentioned is that you
know you can you can potentially try and
fit a curve to historical growth and
just extrapolate forward that curve and
whether you frame it as there have been
a few Transitions and stochastically
there might be a future transition or
there's some underlying Trend in which
growth rates are accelerating and then
that might continue in either way those
either methodology would kind of give
you some number or range by which we
might have much faster growth than we
have now
and that's a very simple not very
ai-centric methodology for example it
could be implicitly forecasting
something else that causes that much
growth such as uh you know mind
uploading where rather than developing
AI systems it's humans whose minds are
able to be accelerated a lot by being
put on computers so that's one
methodology that's kind of Broad and big
picture and um open philanthropy
researchers David Rudman and Tom
Davidson have reports out about that
methodology
you could have a survey of AI
researchers or economists or whoever you
think might have relevant expertise
and there there have been a couple
surveys done by Pacha Grace at AI
impacts
um and you could also kind of take
a a like broad outside view picture of
the development of the AI field where
you could say something like well you
know AI as a field has an except hasn't
existed for too long it's existed since
say 1950 or 1940 depending on how you
count
um so the whole field hasn't been
working for too much and it's been
growing so more of the work is kind of
concentrated in the recent years so you
could have laplace's law of succession
type methodology where you say well
we've been working for 70 years or maybe
the last 50 years are the most important
so we probably won't get AI in the next
20 years but we plausibly will get it in
the next 70 years just because
we haven't really ruled out that AI can
be developed in 140 years of effort
because we've only gone through 70 years
of that and then you can refine this a
little more uh by observing that you
know investment has been accelerating
the field has never been this uh
well-funded and this large before and so
you might want to make kind of simple
boosts for that sort of observation does
this rely on an estimate of how much
progress we've made towards
transformative AI then say that we've
made 50 progress in 70 years and then we
is that is that the methodology that's
not the methodology the methodology is
simpler than that it's based on
um this mathematician Pierre Simone
LaPlace had this very simple formula for
determining the probability of an event
that has never happened before so if you
flip a bunch of coins
um and they all come up heads you don't
think the probability of tails is zero
on the next flip and the way he
suggested estimating that probability
the bias of the coin is as assuming that
you had two virtual coins one which was
heads and one which was tails that you
saw before you started making your
observations so basically you would
determine the probability of tails in
that situation if you had 10 heads in a
row as you know ten plus one over ten
plus two
by adding in the virtual head and the
virtual tale
um so if we're applying this methodology
to forecasting Technologies the only
observation we're really thinking of is
you know it hasn't happened yet so this
is kind of the methodology that someone
living in a cave that every year just
gets the information you know they
haven't developed Tai yet would
would place on the on the probability of
developing Tai in the next
10 years okay makes sense so it's it's a
very simple method but you you went with
with none of these methods you went with
these with this method of biological
anchors so so why why is that method
better in your opinion yeah so there's a
there's a spectrum of how inside view
methodologies are versus how outside
view they are
um and the methodologies that I
described are are more outside view
um than the one I'm using and we should
mention what you mean by inside view and
outside View yeah so um
inside view is roughly kind of having a
relatively detailed model of some
phenomenon that you use to make
predictions about it or think about it
so you know if you were trying to
predict uh who would win an election say
an inside view methodology might involve
more thinking about you know the the
relative merits of the candidates and
which ones seem to have better positions
and which ones have more which one has
more Charisma Etc whereas an outside
view methodology kind of just uses
reference class forecasting which means
you kind of regressed to a prior of
saying you know roughly half the time
one of the candidates wins and roughly
half the time the other wins so that's
going to be my estimate fantastic
in the case of transformative AI you
can't really have truly outside view
estimates in the sense that I described
because you know we haven't seen many
observations of transformative AI in
other worlds that we can just do a
reference class forecast over but the
methodologies I've talked about are sort
of closer in spirit to that so the
laplace's law of succession trying not
to use very much information about AI
and the economic forecasting is also
trying not to use very much information
about AI so the method that I used in my
report
um uses more information about AI
systems and is more detailed in general
um but I think it's important to have
these other simpler methods in mind
because if the estimates were kind of
wildly off between what I
concluded in this report and what these
simpler methods would have said I think
that would be attention worth exploring
and I think in fact
if you kind of look at
um Holden karnovsky on his blog cold
takes has a post called AI forecasting
where the arguments and the experts
stand in which he basically has a table
that goes through all these methods that
I just talked about
and they definitely have different
estimates but it's not the case that the
outside view estimates say you know AI
is impossible this century and my
estimates say 50 in 30 years it's not
that big of a gap and so it's important
to have these outside view estimates as
background as sort of the
um prior that you need to overcome the
like baseline from which you start
updating
makes perfect sense okay but um
let's let's try to explain what
biological angers are
so biological anchors
um are this idea that you might try to
forecast when human level AI systems
might be developed uh by supposing that
the like
amount of computation that you need to
run a human level AI system is roughly
as much computation as the human brain
itself runs on if you were to view it as
a computer so um open philanthropy
researcher Joseph Carl Smith has a
report about how much computation
is the human brain running on if we
imagine it as a computer and there are
you know a lot of philosophical
subtleties there as well as a lot of
Neuroscience details that um could move
your estimate but broadly
um his conclusion which is similar to
the conclusions of of other people
historically who went through this
exercise
um is that
the human brain runs on 10 to the 15
floating Point operations per second
where floating Point operations per
second is this measure of how powerful a
computer is roughly it's asking how many
simple calculations like adding two
numbers or multiplying two numbers can
this system perform per second
um so that would be saying the brain the
human brain performs roughly one
quadrillion simple calculations like
that per second in the course of seeing
things and talking and all this stuff
so if you start from the premise that
well you know the human brain is this
artifact this computer
um built by Evolution
um and it's you know so efficient you
know it has uh 10 to the 15 floating
Point operations that it does per second
um
you you start from the premise that
Evolution performed this large search
over many millions billions of years
um on brain designs
um and
it was optimizing for organisms to have
higher genetic fitness to have more
descendants in expectation other things
being equal consuming more energy or
resources to do the same thing
um likely reduces your genetic fitness
so in that sense we say that Evolution
as a search process an optimization
process is providing some pressure to
keep this number down
um or rather to increase this number in
floating Point operations per second to
make it so that a given brain can be
more powerful with a similar amount of
energy usage
so we're saying this is kind of a
variable that Evolution was quote
unquote trying to optimize
um and so we might expect it to be
difficult to design an artifact that is
way way more efficient than the human
brain while still having its same
abilities so we might guess that
whenever we develop transformative AI or
human level AI it might need to run on
as much computation as we believe the
human brain runs on that's sort of like
broadly the amount of resources it takes
to create this level of intelligence or
ability if you're trying to use
resources economically in a very broad
sense
so that's the starting premise
um and this starting premise has been
used by various people in the 80s and
90s to try to forecast AI system uh
forecast AI progress and forecast human
level AI so notably Hans moravec
computer scientist that has a forecast
that starts from this premise
um in I think 92 Ray Kurzweil is a
futurist that also uses this kind of
premise and methodology to try to
forecast AI progress so that kind of
frame isn't novel
the thing that the report does that is
more novel is
um
asking okay you know what if we say that
we're trying to
um build a system that has this much
computation
but rather than building it directly
with humans you know working with a
computer that big and trying to write a
software program that's as powerful as
the brain which is kind of implicitly
what borovec and kurtzweil were
imagining
um let's imagine that we use modern
machine learning techniques to train a
system that runs on that much
computation so how much computation
would it take to use modern deep
learning techniques to train a model
that is as big as we believe the human
brain is in terms of computation
so that was the kind of additional
premise that my report brought in
because it seems like unlikely at this
point that we will kind of hand code an
AI system and that it seems likely to be
some sort of machine learning process
and we at that time in 2020 had had just
started to have some data about how
training these systems tends to scale
like how much data it takes to train a
system of a certain size and so it was
kind of this opportunity to try and
extrapolate from that data that we were
starting to get
um to get a sense for how much data and
how much computation would it take to
train a model that's the size of the
brain and so that's the question that
the report is asking
um and the report is
saying that that might be like a proxy
to
the question of when we might train
transformative AI systems so it's kind
of a different question in that we're
asking about
when we might be able to afford to train
one kind of unified system that's like
more of a classical AGI type system
that's the size of the human brain that
can do everything humans can do or you
know a large subset of the most
important things humans can do
we might get transformative AI in other
ways you know for example we might get
transformative AI by having you know
many smaller systems that each do more
specialized things but the Insight here
is that
if you can name one specific way of
getting transformative AI that in some
sense seems kind of brute forcey just
training a giant machine learning model
then by the time that path is Affordable
it seems plausible that we would have
gotten transformative AI either through
that path or through something even more
efficient that you know we discovered
through human Ingenuity so in that sense
you can kind of think of it as an upper
Bound for timelines uh but I don't
believe it to be like too loose of an
upper bound
um I think for various reasons just
because things are difficult and they
take time I'm more inclined to treat
this as something like a median so
conceptually it might be an upper bound
but to just account for how often these
kinds of forecasts are oversimplified
and how this kind of forecast in the
past has has tended to overestimate how
quickly AI progress would go I'm kind of
treating that as a median
okay so we should mention the conclusion
of the report and your your further
thinking about when we might have
transformative AI so you mentioned that
this might be a we could see it as a
median or as a conceptual upper bound
what are the numbers here what are we
talking
yeah so the conclusion of the report at
the time was that um there's roughly a
50 chance that the amount
the msized AI model would be available
by 2050 so that was the median of the
report which is 30 years from the time
the report was written
um and there was a spread from there
where there was significant probability
on you know 20 36 which was the year
that I chose to investigate for the
report because in the past Holden
karnovsky had written a post in 2016
saying that he thought there was a 10
chance of transformative AI in 20 years
from then so I was kind of investigating
that
um as part of this report so there's
significant probabilities on sooner than
that but the the median was 2050. 2050
that seems very very close to the
present yes but you've you've moved your
your AI or Tai timelines even closer to
the present in the meantime
yeah so
um I recently wrote an update Post in
which I said that over the last two
years I've updated toward it being more
like 2040 as a median
um so there are a few reasons for that
one is that I had a in the report I was
imagining that in order to train AI
systems to be as useful as humans they
would have to
the AI system would itself have to learn
as quickly as humans can learn and as
efficiently as humans can learn so this
is not the like learning process that
trains the AI system which might be
analogous to Evolution this is the AI
system itself like the computer program
while it's running should be able to
learn as efficiently as humans can in
order to be as useful as them and so
the process that produces the AI system
seems likely to be some sort of meta
learning so the task that it's teaching
the AI is the task of learning new
things efficiently and that seemed
potentially harder to train and than
many of the tasks that we had done so up
to that point like image recognition and
language modeling were all these pretty
short Horizon tasks where you get really
dense feedback but if the task you're
trying to learn is learning itself where
um you kind of encounter a new system
interact with it for a few hours
discover something about it and use what
you discover to
do something useful that whole process
takes longer
um to pay off as either you did well or
you didn't do well so you kind of have a
sparser feedback signal here
and that might make training take longer
so a naive guess would be that it takes
kind of linearly longer if you have a
feedback signal every
you know one second of a certain level
of quality in one training run and in a
different training run you have a
similar level of quality of feedback
signal every one hour
um than you might expect the second one
to take 3 600 times as much as the first
one because you kind of need just as
many data points if you're training a
model of a similar size but each data
point is more expensive for you to
produce involves the model running for
longer involves collecting more data
um more like kind of
environment frames or whatever
um so I had that as a premise
um that I put significant weight on in
the report in 2020 and I I did have a
bunch of stuff that I said then of how
you know it might be shorter than that
or easier than that systems that are
trained on like pretty short Horizon
tasks we might be able to kind of put
them together and compose them in order
to do these higher level more useful
tasks without having to train in them
the ability to learn themselves
I think over the course of the last
couple years I updated toward it being
like more likely that
systems could have transformative
impacts while not really having this
meta learning ability so in some sense I
lowered my bar for what transformative
even means
um
because
programming and software engineering
tasks are tasks where you have
unusually much data lying out there in
the world and data that can be produced
by you know employees at tech companies
just doing their normal jobs and it
seems unusually rich in feedback based
on you can see whether your code worked
you can see whether it passed tests and
so on
and it seems like
A system that was able to do all these
software engineering tasks
not through the human methodology of
learning things quickly and adapting
quickly but through a different
methodology of just having memorized a
lot of stuff and just kind of already
knowing a lot of things on the basis of
its training
it seems like that in itself might be
enough to kick off a transformative
change of the kind that we're talking
about because
that kind of set of activities of
programming could be used to make AI
systems themselves improve in various
ways and it would it would essentially
accelerate AI research and a previous
premise of our work is that AI research
will eventually produce this thing that
accelerates the entire economy or has
the potential to accelerate the entire
economy so in a like as a very
simplistic case if I thought that in
2040 it would take 10 years of research
from the human field to be able to
produce transformative AI from that
point then any technology that's sped up
AI progress itself would kind of bring
that date forward so if they had a
system that speeds up AI progress by 10x
then the research that I thought had to
be done would instead be done in one
year so kind of lowering the bar for
transformative Ai and believing that
um narrowly software engineering might
be a lot of the like first task that we
need to clear
and also that uh in order to get that
software engineering task we maybe don't
need meta learning we don't need systems
that are that are good at handling
totally novel situations because we can
instead have systems that rely on having
memorized and seen a lot more than any
human programmer has seen
um caused me to to kind of like
shift more toward the estimates that
would be produced if you assume that
that the task you're training
transformative AI on is uh highly dense
in its feedback signals
so that was one thing I think that was
the biggest thing that caused the update
a couple other things another one is
that I had a sort of very simple
extrapolations for Hardware progress
software progress and money spent
training AI systems in my report so I
spent most time kind of thinking about
how how much computation would it take
to train an AI system that had this
transformative impact if we had to do it
today and then I combined that with
forecasts of you know
how are how are our architectures
becoming more efficient
um how is our spending increasing how is
Hardware getting cheaper to to
extrapolate that forward into a
probability that the amount of
computation would be affordable
so I had these like very simple
trendline based forecasts for those
three things
um but actually there's a potentially
important
feedback loop in those things where if
early AI systems have
you know exciting applications even if
they're narrow that's likely to attract
more investment into the field so
investment speeds up and then the
greater investment into the field is
probably going to cause more people to
go into research which causes
accelerations in software progress and
Hardware progress so it's a demand
driven acceleration of all of those
things that I had been kind of plotting
as static trend lines also contributes
to expecting progress to be sooner so
this is kind of dependent on uh you
don't get
transformative AI all at once you kind
of get some some earlier applications
that make money attract investment and
kind of speed up that whole track toward
getting transformed about
to many listeners this these timelines
or these predictions within a median of
2040 will seem incredibly fast or this
is right around the corner
um and so it it it will sound
unbelievable but of course as I think
it's obvious to everyone listening to
this a lot of workers has gone into to
the report you're talking about a lot of
thinking has gone into this and how how
can we try to test this the conclusions
of this report against is are there
sanity checks we can we can run to see
whether we have we have kind of
theorized ourselves into it into a
corner with the with this report and
specifically I'm talking about this
survey you mentioned earlier by catech
race where she surveys uh 700 machine
learning researchers and they conclude
that with a 50 probability we will have
human level AI by 2059 and by human
level AI they mean that machines Can Can
it can do every task better than human
workers so it's a bit of a different
um
it's a pretty similar roughly similar
yeah roughly similar so I I think when
we do this the sanity check there there
is something to um to what you're saying
but how would you how would you value
the the information you got from from
working on the report versus these
surveys of machine learning experts
yes I
[Music]
agree about that survey is that um there
was some clear evidence that people
weren't thinking about the question very
hard so you reported the kind of median
probability of human level AI but the
question also asked a number of
different a number of different
questions to kind of like pin down the
logical structure of their beliefs here
and
for a lot of individual tasks that were
pulled out of name such as when would it
be the case that AIS can automate
machine learning research or when would
it be the case that AIS can automate
math research um
those experts actually gave longer
answers than the answer they gave for
when every task would be audited and so
you know that's like it's hard to be
like consistent and it was an
overlapping but different set of people
that got the different questions uh but
it's sort of an indication that I'd I
think that even if all of these machine
learning researchers have intuition from
their jobs that is informative for
timelines which I think is true the way
that was elicited and expressed in this
survey where they just kind of thought
about the question and gave an answer
is sort of
clearly lacking in some ways
um
so so that's kind of one
point I want to make
another thing I want to say is that
at least recently it feels like many
machine learning researchers have
underestimated progress over the last
few years so Jacob steinhardt who's a
professor at Berkeley ran a forecasting
contest I think it began in 2021 early
2021 in which he asked super forecasters
like professional forecasters that
forecast things like political events
and also machine learning researchers
when AI systems would reach 50 on a
couple of benchmarks a sort of general
knowledge Benchmark and a math benchmark
and both groups of people actually
substantially underestimated progress in
that those benchmarks were cleared in
2022 and the distribution generated by
the forecasts placed very low
probability on that and the median of
the distribution was something more like
2026.
so it does seem like it's the case that
at least recently machine learning
researchers uh may have a tendency to
kind of underestimate progress in the
field
also maybe because maybe there aren't
really any expert experts at forecasting
um transformative AI or so if if you're
a professor of machine learning you you
specialize in some very
um specific aspects of of maybe the
training process and and you're maybe
you're not your date you're always
thinking about predicting when we will
have a transformative Ai and so maybe
maybe there are actually far fewer
experts in this area than we than we
might believe
I think that's right I think they're
definitely different jobs and I don't
think there's really anybody who's an
expert in AI forecasting it's a very uh
immature field forecasting in general is
a very immature field and an AI
timelines forecasting is especially so
um you know
Holden once joked that asking machine
learning researchers to forecast when
will get transformative AI sort of like
asking the CEOs of oil companies to
forecast climate change it's just like
uh different skill sets
um or even the CEOs of renewable energy
companies to forecast climate change
outcomes
those are just different things like
working on a technology is different
from having the kind of background and
thought process to forecast where that
technology will go
when you're thinking about
transformative AI are you assuming that
we won't need any any
radically new insights and that we can
get to transformative AI by the machine
learning techniques that we already have
today
yeah so um when I
described my previous forecast as being
a sort of soft upper bound
um this was based on uh having a high
probability in that report it was 80
percent of something in the spectrum of
training a large machine learning model
being sufficient for transformative AI
um some of those values in the Spectrum
are extremely expensive you know very
close to replicating all the computation
done by Evolution and if in fact
that's what it would take to get
transformative AI through this like
train a big model Brute Force way I
expect actually
people would find something more clever
that that did involve insights to avoid
paying such a large cost
um so in that sense it's kind of a soft
upper bound of like some of these like
more expensive ways of getting
transformative AI from using machine
learning techniques are really very
Brute Force
um and I think they would plausibly
succeed if we had that astronomical
level of resources but
in fact if we
if that's what it would take to do
things with deep learning probably
people would invent something more
efficient than that
on the lower end
um if you imagine all you kind of need
to do is train a large machine learning
model with fairly dense feedback signals
um kind of similar to the training
regimes we have now
there I think that suggests that
this technique is is pretty simple but
it might get us to transformative AI
before
big breakthrough insights have time to
happen because those are pretty
stochastic
um and and relatively rare by their
nature so
um because it in the report and
especially now I have relatively short
timelines I expect a relatively high
probability that we kind of just turns
out it's pretty straightforward to build
these systems and
I definitely think that there's going to
be algorithmic progress there's going to
be better architectures better
optimization algorithms better loss
functions you know a lot of things will
improve in the way things tend to and
that will play a role in making the
systems making it affordable to train a
transformative model But ultimately I
don't expect something that we would in
retrospect all a big game-changing
paradigm shift
it's basically a game of scale then
getting lots of computing power getting
lots of of training data and um and
running these uh training these models
in very expensive ways
uh yeah that's my Mainline picture it's
definitely very uncertain and I think if
you told me that we don't develop
transformative AI in the next 20 to 30
years my probability that when we
actually do develop it it involves a
paradigm shift and like kind of larger
insights goes up a lot
okay
let's talk about something that might
slow down this this picture of when we
could get to transformative AI it seems
to me that if you have if if you're
running a scientific research program
you have to collect lots of data from
from The Real World and that takes a
number of years maybe you also have to
get regulatory approval to run some
experiments and already there you're
you're talking you could be talking
about five or seven years before you
could get some result so if you if we
imagine AI doing science for us wouldn't
it run into these same limits of
collecting empirical data or regulation
so this is you're asking about suppose
after we have ai systems that could
automate science
um going from there to having an impact
in terms of accelerated growth yes so
how How would how would this transfer
this um
very Advanced system have this impact if
it leads to engage with um with the
physical world in a way where the
feedback is very slow over a number of
years so how could this happen in the
next 20 years if it takes say two years
or five years to get regulatory approval
to run an experiment
yeah so
um broadly my answer is that I imagine
that AI will be disproportionately
applied to areas where there aren't a
lot of Regulation and I think there are
many of those areas so you know
programming and computer science in
general computer hacking and things like
that
um trading so they're they're kind of
like large
swaths of the economy that are kind of
maybe not consumer facing and not
labeled as explicit like this is science
and it's in the domain of science that
could produce a lot of value
that people just kind of can do what
they want in so like anything that's the
domain of a Silicon Valley startup I
think could be radically transformed by
such a system just like
you know you need to have regulatory
approval to do phase two trials on some
drug on humans say
but just inventing
you know insanely good virtual
reality technology or just making a lot
of money on the stock market like making
inventing like
very compelling and persuasive kinds of
art like there's just a lot of things
that are are sort of unregulated and
people just do them now
um and AI systems could just do them
then and this goes for things like you
know um Alpha fold was developed by
deepmind this is a model that
based on a protein's molecular structure
predicts its three-dimensional form like
how it will fold up into a
three-dimensional object and this had
been a very difficult and important
question for a long time
um but like uh
the way they trained this AI system
didn't really involve interacting with
anything physical they trained it on a
number of proteins and their
three-dimensional forms and it kind of
picked up on these patterns
um so I do agree that when you have ai
systems that are able to think a lot
faster than humans and are a lot more
numerous than humans the
balance of like relatively speaking
interacting with the physical world and
getting some result back from the
physical world becomes very painful
um and you know from the perspective of
those AI systems they might be waiting a
lifetime or multiple lifetimes to get
some result back from the real world but
I think that will result in systems
shifting a lot of effort to having
really accurate simulations
um and having like really efficient
experimental designs so when they do
interact with the real world they try a
lot of experiments in parallel the
experiments have been like winnowed down
to testing like some pretty specific
hypotheses that couldn't be ruled out at
simulation and so on
um so things like drug Discovery and so
on I think will still be accelerated
even if the
part of the process where you make a
physical drug and you test it on animals
and you're tested on humans isn't
particularly accelerated just because
the part of the ideation part of the
process which Narrows down you know a
whole universe of possibilities into a
few drugs you actually try to develop is
greatly accelerated
um and there's greater search power to
to pick out the things in that space
that are likely to actually work and
have major impacts
it's an interesting picture of the
future in which all that's all
everything that's digital might be
moving much faster than everything
that's physical yeah could we could we
see for example housing staying
relatively the same while we get
incredibly Advanced virtual reality or
drug Discovery or anything that's that's
purely digital
um I do think that
the digital world will be moving faster
than the physical world but one of the
things that I think is not particularly
regulated where you don't need IRB
approval right now is building robots
and you have a lot of robotic startups
and I think one of the tasks that we
would put these AI scientists and
Engineers toward is designing better
smaller cheaper robots so
and and robots that like physically move
faster than humans can like skitter
around like bugs or whatever
um so I think that kind of Advance would
speed up physical manufacturing of all
kinds as well
um you know less so and less immediately
than the digital world is sped up
um but I don't think the Gap is you know
10 plus years between those two things
given that you can pour a lot of purely
digital effort into producing really
efficient robots you might even be able
to train the robots in a simulated
environment and then transfer what
they've learned in that environment into
the digital world yeah into the physical
world into the into the physical world
yes of course
um let's talk about training data
because this is very important if we're
thinking about the training machine
learning models is it it could it be the
case that we we are running out of data
um it's as I understand it many of the
most recent language models and image
models are trained on large parts of the
data on the internet so is it the case
that data is a is a limiting factor in
how good these models can be
I think data is plausibly
you know if you asked me how I might be
wrong about my aggressive timelines
forecasts I do think data is is one of
the one one of the few things I would I
would maybe point at as potentially
causing a big swing I haven't thought
about this as much as I'd like to but
here are kind of a few reasons why
I at least don't think it's appropriate
to be confident that this would stall
progress so one thing is that
as you get to AI systems that are very
large and very expensive single training
runs the compute could cost you know a
billion dollars or something
when you're in that regime it becomes
affordable and sensible to pay human
beings a lot of money to generate data
or provide RL supervision
um where that isn't really the case now
if you spend a million dollars on a
training run you kind of want to just
scrape up passive data because you don't
want to pay many humans by the hour to
produce demonstrations for your model or
to judge which of the model's
completions are are better so when
you're kind of in this regime where
where things are much more expensive I
think
yes you might run out of passive data
but
it might be much more worthwhile to have
literally human scientists human
software Engineers think about what kind
of data they could produce that would
cause this model to learn something more
efficiently and produce that data and
you could also use smaller models to
produce that kind of data to train
larger models and if we move more toward
a reinforcement learning regime then we
move more to a regime where the model is
generating its own data and the learning
is in saying which of two answers it
gave to a question was better and so
then you kind of produce quote unquote
data just by running the model
um
and they're in particular some things
that might enhance general intelligence
or reasoning ability uh that are
functionally infinite data so if you're
training a model to play chess or or any
kind of zero-sum board game
um or to prove theorems and Mathematics
uh there's you know you can kind of
procedurally generate infinite data in
those domains you can ask the model to
prove any number of like theorems that
you generate
um you can ask the model to
play itself in chess you know as many
times as you want because you have this
kind of compact description of what the
game is and you just run it every time
to generate a new data point for the
model so yeah the combination of
it seems worthwhile to pay humans to
generate data or provide RL supervision
the model can generate its own data in
an RL context and there are at least
some environments that we haven't fully
tapped out which have functionally
infinite data suggests to me that at
least if
the
kind of level of training we need for
transformative AI the size of the model
is not too enormous we might be able to
you know find creative ways to
get the data that it needs
okay this this is a bit of a risky
question in the sense that it is a
question that
when asked in the past people have been
kind of embarrassed by by how how things
actually turned out so my question is
whether there is some kind of human
secret Source maybe it's creativity
maybe it's um
some some ability we have that cannot be
learned by these machine learning models
um I'm thinking of of if if you're if if
we're interested in in whether
um AI can do science then we're also
interested in in the kind of the biggest
scientific breakthroughs we can imagine
so developing a new theory in physics
for example
is it possible to learn how to develop a
new theory in physics only by uh reading
whatever or processing whatever data
already exists or is there some kind of
leap of creativity involved in that in
that process
yeah so I
I have a few different responses to
different parts of that
um one is
I don't imagine that we'll end up
Training Systems purely by consuming and
reading I think systems will end up
doing a lot of learning by doing so in
the case of a physics model
um a lot of its training would involve
reading papers on the internet
um but a lot of its training would also
involve
proposing
experiments
um and being told how good its
experiment proposal was you know writing
papers and getting feedback on the
papers it writes and generally doing
things and getting reinforcement
learning feedback from those things
um and if you really cared about getting
a system that was very good at producing
insights in physics you would also try
to be really careful about its
curriculum you'd start
you'd have it start out doing
short things that had dense feedback
that were relatively easy and then you'd
kind of iteratively move it toward
harder things to kind of give it a good
learning curve
um
so that was kind of one point in terms
of I don't think and I would kind of
share some of your skepticism
if you were imagining getting
transformative AI purely through Reading
and predicting what you'll see next in
the text that you're reading and then
the other thing I want to say is that I
don't think growth is mainly driven by
these like
Big Sexy Cool insights that come along
rarely like you know I don't think
I think Einstein contributed definitely
punched above his weight in terms of
generating economic insight and the
stuff he thought about ended up being
used in GPS systems and stuff but like
if you think about the total amount of
economic value that has been produced by
like full sexy insights versus like more
plotting work
um I think that the more plotting work
as a whole as a block has contributed
like far more to economic value like you
know little r d iteration things that
are not that you wouldn't have you know
Legends written about later uh I are
gonna be
easier to train AI systems to do and are
actually collectively more important
than the really cool insights and this
was part of what moved me to
lowering the bar in my mind that I was
imagining for transformative AI systems
because having a kind of
somewhat closer interaction with how
machine learning research is done you
know obviously machine learning
researchers are very intelligent and
they have creative ideas all the time
but often it's kind of like
you you try a like tweak on something
that was tried before people had that
idea before but uh you know maybe
something got a little bit easier and
it's a little bit more practical to try
that thing now so you try it
um and it's like you know one
incremental
Improvement on your system and you have
many of those uh and and that seems to
be what drives progress more although
there are big insights occasionally
and then the finally like addressing the
first thing you were talking about is
there a human Special Sauce that we
can't train these systems to learn
I do think that on a very abstract level
there are going to be
some
cognitive skills where humans just
happen by chance to be much better
suited to those skills than AI systems
and I think that doesn't necessarily
mean that no amount of training and no
size of model could be taught those
skills but it might mean that the first
transformative systems lack some
abilities that humans have and so it's
not the case that the first
transformative systems are going to be
like be able to do exactly what humans
do or exactly a superset of what humans
do but that there's going to be some
Venn diagram where they're able to do a
lot of the things that humans can do you
know sometimes better than us sometimes
worse than us and they'll have some
skills that we don't have at all and
will have some skills that they don't
really have at all and if I had to guess
at what those skills might be I think it
would go back to efficient learning
um
where
I think that probably the first
transformative systems will
know what to do in a lot of situations
by virtue of having consumed much more
information that humans could consume in
their lifetime and will be relatively
weaker at
uh quickly picking up on something
that's totally novel I think we'll
eventually develop AI systems that are
better than humans that everything
humans do but I think that's a higher
bar than is necessary for transformative
Ai and that higher bar might be achieved
through
our kind of like first transformative AI
systems doing AI research eventually
leading to a different Paradigm
um and the kind of like smarter systems
that are superhuman in every domain
might be built in a very different way
from
plain deep learning even if the first
transformative AI systems are playing
deep learning
that's it for this episode on the next
episode I talked with ajaya about how AI
development might lead to catastrophe
a jail is out a concrete scenario for
how the incentives of today's AI
development could cause Humanity to lose
control over our AI systems